[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
super pumped to have Poe Brunson joining
us for his second round on the show hey
man thanks yeah hi thanks for coming on
yeah so pumped
we just did an awesome panel together on
identifying correct and perverse
incentives we did but I thought the last
time I was on simulation would've been
five months ago four months ago nine
months ago I was in November yeah yeah
and we we did a really good job on
packing Poe's seven New York Times
bestsellers we talked a lot about his
journey as an author that was really fun
you guys can find the link to that
interview in the bio below if you wanna
check that out for those who don't know
Poe Brunson is a seven-time New York
Times bestselling author and strategy
director now at Indy bio focused on we
conceptualize and complex challenges
into more elegant forms he previously
co-founded the writers grotto a
workspace for 125 professional writers
in San Francisco you can find the links
in the Bob little poll Brunson
constantly calm as well as Indy bio and
SF grotto
org also post Twitter and his book link
profile you can find all his books
they're highly recommend checking them
out polo start things off with talking
about this really this big transition
that you made to strategy director at
Indy bio and why do you make this
transition what do you see in this field
of biotech why did it attract you okay
so they're both two sides of it one is
my journey as a writer and the other
side is just in all those years I was
writing what I didn't get to do and I
would say that four to five four years
ago as a writer the grotto
I would wander the halls to other
writers saying stuff that they didn't
understand like my publisher is just
another corporation there's nothing
different about big French conglomerate
happens to do make money publishing
books but it just treats us like anybody
else you know to writers shouldn't be
neutral anymore they should be from a
place
not just write about things I didn't
know what I was experience I just have
this tapping into these feelings I felt
fundamentally when it came to our
concerns and worries where the world is
headed in the future that we're going to
create future that we're going to fight
for I had this narrative sense that what
I was writing had okay people like what
do you mean II didn't have credibility
like your seventh I know you have nine
national awards I'm like people have the
right to hear from the people actually
doing it people stress and worry makes
them want to skip the intermediator skip
the media hear from the here here right
here the truth right out of people doing
it mm-hmm
and and even though journalists we take
people into that professionally there's
still this extent to which the
journalist has a commentator as a as a
philosopher as an interpreter yeah like
really has to kinda like like there are
things you know from having done things
that are different from things you know
from having studied thing experiences
that you've had teach you a different
kind of wisdom then what you can get
from like scouring the internet trying
to educate yourself going to school to
learn it you know and people want to
hear from that side of the equation
and in this world and I thought that's
right they had the right to and that for
me I needed to be a doer not just a
thinker and I was the previous four
years sort of having this feeling and
kind of looking for like where where
where could I manifest this and I would
wander around the house saying you know
to my kids I could well you guys go off
to college I'm gonna go back to college
and then I'm gonna get out of college
and I'm gonna get a job like you the job
like you've never ready why would you
want a job you haven't had a job in 25
years it seems like a great life and and
you know all of these things were
calling me
and I listen to him it's kind of person
I am without knowing we what they meant
and I and I've been it any bio for about
a year working as strategy director
since January first but but that call
I'm gonna been a fan of anybody around
me but a lot of these accelerators and
incubators and moonshot places and think
tanks and really was attracted to the
pace of doing things their biology is a
challenge because I don't have expertise
in biology per se at all but it's
another sort of ultimately a language
and a thing to learn yeah my wife is a
genetic engineer so I have it in the
house and I've been around it for 30
years but you know it was really
artistically wanting to be biased now
this is weird because journalists are
supposed to be unbiased were supposed to
present an unbiased view of the world
and I was obviously bias has infiltrated
the media and all this stuff and I'm not
saying this is just only as a reaction
to the fact that my media has become
biased I'm saying just well even if all
the last five years was happening media
hadn't happened that took to be biased
to actually say not only is this really
what I think but like the added benefit
of being an SOS vegan ad bio was not
only this is what I think I believe that
so much I'm not just telling you I'm
putting starting out with a quarter
million dollars welcoming going up to
millions of dollars because I believe it
so much and to actually use that bias in
a different way and to be able to access
and educate inspire to actually access
that people will hear Arbonne and I are
working on a book the people will hear
it in a different way biology as an
engineer is such a cool way of viewing
the feel
it's again like we're not taking people
into the halls of in Dubai oh it's not a
book about anybody is a book about the
world that we all live in everyday just
from our point of view they're on and
and informed by like the effort of
solving human and Planetary health and
the science involved to do it but the
book is the book is every chapter is
sort of short and it begins with a
normal news headline from everyday sort
of stuff you would read that paints the
fact that the world is in chaos and the
world is mutating but just everyday
stuff that you wake up every morning and
we started riffing off of that and we
turn every chapter into an experiment it
so it's a it's reinterpreting the world
you got hooked into augmenting human and
Planetary health through biology through
accelerating biology to accelerating
this so didn't you buy out a store eat
and I worked there and that's what I do
but that's that's my artistic voice
isn't necessarily rooted per se in that
I do believe that fundamentally biology
is intensely critical because of the
fundamental I guess I don't want to jump
at like but there is this incredible
problem of the natural world's resources
I'm not talk about protecting the
natural I was talking about like we're
running out of sand and in 70 countries
like sand they're like we thought
gangs controlled diamonds and
prostitutes and drugs and now they're
just stealing beaches in 70 countries
around the world and there's a shortage
of sand because all the sands been
sucked up to be used in concrete for all
the new buildings and China has used
more concrete in the last four years in
the u.s. used in a hundred years it's
it's ironic in a world that's been
covered by desert where desertification
and the amount of land that is equal to
the size of North Korea or Bulgaria
every year is turning to sand and yet we
have a sand shortage mm-hmm ironically
because desert sand is windblown so it's
too small fine and powdery so it can't
be used in concrete so we're covering
the sand but have a say in shortage and
the you know this the if if just
the middle-income countries the three
billion people in Brazil Russia India
Malaysia China grow to a Western
standard of living which is what they're
on track to do by 2050 absolutely we
would need for earth of natural
resources so what it's funded my says is
to bring all technologies to bear but
like the kind of stuff we can do
digitally and our all the kind of cool
new things fundamentally the idea that
future technologies are going to bring
us new things we've never seen before is
really that's a tiny slice of what it
has to do and that's actually a bias to
look for that or even mean entranced by
it is oversight to the material and
physical world that we're on and how do
we reinvent the very means of production
and using these resources using things
that we don't even who thinks of sand is
a technology we all think of sand is a
technology but it's massive part of
concreting concrete's probably been like
second most powerful technology in
humans history so how we build
everything if you look at I don't say
it's like it's not psychologically
important it's not metaphorically
important no writer thinks it's
important no it's not ethically you know
it's just more like actually being used
can we bio and tech fast enough to
innovate on this dilemma where so many
people are rising into higher
socioeconomic statuses and are gonna be
consuming more resources so can we
innovate fast enough could we also
dematerialize and maybe spiritualize
ourselves more along the way grow
ethically and morally and all embody
some of these roots of indigenous wisdom
that you come from source that you
identify what your North Star is you go
on that journey if I bring these fruits
to yourself your family in your
community in the world and if we can do
those things effectively maybe pare the
spiritual wisdom the dematerialization
with the innovation in science and
technology while people also
economically
that's kind of a pretty good vision for
how to I feel have strong prosperity if
only one of those things comes online
it's not as good as if more of them came
online and so it's kind of a
multi-faceted awakening around the
planet to these dilemmas that we face
and to leveraging the technologies
embodying the wisdoms these types of
things so can we do that is that you're
asking it's as though that that's
paramount that's paramount yeah it's
apparent right so the question is are we
yeah we want to have we have to do that
I just want to say that like there's
this thing I've been doing a lot of
thinking and writing about the way we
think about the future and there's these
pitfalls in it and there's these mental
traps and whirlpools that suck us it and
one of them I actually call it effect
indeterminacy and it relates to whether
you're effect are you optimistic about
the future or you're pessimistic
okay sure and we we believe that this is
sort of important and that we need to be
optimistic often or the pessimists come
off as more credible and I would argue
that they don't matter than two sides
the same coin and they're actually we
call effect in two determinacy after
electron and determinacy that the very
act of looking for the electron means
it's not there and it's somewhere else
in the same way the very act of asking
when you feel positive or do you feel
negative causes you to feel the opposite
and so I will say that as we talk here I
want to say that whether whether I get
positive or negative actually is
irrelevant they both lead to being
pro-change and that the real villain
here is inertia is inertia is the tense
is the tendency to for the world to stay
the same so you asked we have solutions
yeah whether I could I could name ten
twelve different solutions around
concrete interesting so an optimist
perspective around yeah
we're tackling all these complex
challenges or pessimist perspective
around
we're not tackling them fast enough yeah
that they both are anti inertia they're
anti both anti inertia staying in these
these ruts of the same old code
propagating versus both of as long as a
pessimist isn't completely defeatist
right long as you're not defeatist yeah
a lot of they're both lead to this sort
of like fundamentally we need to adopt
we do have solutions I mean we have 10
or 12 different fixes for concrete all
the dematerialization space is the more
sustainable space and reducing the
carbon so question more carbon filling
them with air building lot of
nanomaterials adding material mixes into
them well number of ways to handle this
thing and we've been hearing about them
for like eight or nine years and even
better ones are coming as we listen to
the labs and hear what's being developed
but in the meantime like in the meantime
like this incredible new solution like
actually isn't being implemented in the
world and instead inertia is prevailing
I think a greatest example of that is is
coal I had Arvind go to Poland just
recently to the black triangle to go
stare into the open pit mines coal there
is nearer the surface in its crappy
brown coal which is like half not coal
is terribly polluting even China has
deep restrictions got burning burning
lignite or brown coal so it's not like
Pennsylvania coal that's pretty pure
carbon and deep in the earth this is so
do they just literally just like half
the size of San Francisco these the mine
is just rip out the earth you don't
don't bore holes don't go down just
stuff just rip it out for like a
thousand feet and just wanted him to
stare at it and see this villain our
villain of inertia and in a world where
people half the people are saying the
world's changing too fast on us here
like no today there's a lot of people
like the turo coal pit which is the
number one greenhouse Gator greenhouse
gas emitter in Poland
and they you might think the world is
we're pulling back from coal you know
history will show that the first half of
the 21st century was the end of coals
long run right I want to give you
another example of inertia and another
experiential wisdom that you can gain
it's so cool that Arvind in Poland
getting this because he's literally
layering old code of the inertia of
burning fossil fuels into his mind so
that he can then go and realize that the
importance of deploying the new codes
and helping fund them and but I wanted
him to have a to put a face to the
abstract thing of a world that refuses
to change yes okay so putting a face to
this world that's refusing to change I
love that and then I want to give you
this other example oh my goodness when I
went and finally toured Recology
I saw the massive garbage dumps I saw
how we recycle I saw the compost I saw
all of that and when you see that it
teaches you that the the garbage cycles
that were in as a planet and where they
go deploy to landfills where they go
deploy to oceans and all the same stuff
is just atrocious and so that just get
lit got layered in and now I'm just you
know your mind gets expanded to that new
realization you put a face to that so
that well into that inertia and then it
excites you more to obsolete those cars
and to go build the new ones right yeah
okay in the case of coal in the two
decades by which we have brought clean
renewable energy online and made it more
economical in those same two decades
when you would think oh we've got
renewable energy now global coal
capacity has doubled doubled the world's
share of electricity in 1970 from coal
was 30 percent today you would think it
would be much lower than that because of
all the other stuff we've got it's 40
percent today like power of inertia is
so powerful people would say oh well
it's just corporate
prophets no it ain't the coal industry
is not profitable four out of ten power
coal power plants are unprofitable to
run but are kept running and even the
United Arab Emirates which has all the
gasoline at wants oil if it wants to use
fossil fuels and be a polluter or all
the desert lands to land sunshine to
make photon solar energy they're
building coal plants like coals and
inertia not just coals inertia I mean
inertia across everything it's so
powerful
damn fifty years of environmental
movement have been no match for inertia
damn and I wanted Arvind you don't see
that and and to understand like I mean
just have a little more fun with it so
don't get like depressing right but like
I was like you know think about all the
bond great Bond villains of the bond
films you know and they're always like
trying to like blow up the world to
screw the world I'm like the greatest
Bond villain ever it would be somebody
with from the worldwide organization of
inertia who's infiltrated government in
finance and whatever and and their that
what they do is they they prevent
technological change from happening hmm
and to so we invented this this inertia
villain in a Bond film to to further
understand what we're up against because
if you look at like what we're doing at
any bio and and what so many other great
labs and places are doing they're all
doing it they're they're the the rate of
innovation around incredible solutions
is insane the rate of actual adoption of
those is comes down to you know a little
solar power and some plant burgers dim
they're not trying to be negative
villains I
just like I like how you you're painting
it in that way it's now multiple people
Yan was just messaging me about this
because Eric Weinstein had put a post up
about also seeing this as a villain some
of the gatekeepers this gated
institutional narrative gatekeepers
right that these are villains in a sense
it lends it we need to put it yeah we
all we generally get the premise like
hey simulation Alan interviews good guys
generally right good people are the good
guys and bad guys male or female
whatever it is or what's going off
questions you know but like but like
like so who are the bad guys what are
the what is the face of this bad guys
it's a face it's not any one company
like it's not any one CEO but there are
some sneaky ass tactics that have been
made with like the deployment of some of
the branding of companies like coca-cola
across the lowest socio-economic areas
around the planet absolutely because I
think he thinks one more example that I
want to mention before he I'll keep
going it's just that another one that
just profoundly changed the way see the
world I'm so happy that it happened in
AP environmental science for me when I
was like 16 17 I went to a
slaughterhouse yeah that's another one
that's just like life-changing when you
see the actual pigs cows chickens just
getting slaughtered when you see them
just getting gas and all trying to
escape for their lives and the massive
blade that just goes chops their throats
slice them in half I mean it's just it
just changes the way that you it's
different today just just so you know
but it's still happening oh but it all
is from around the world of them just
making the light I think it's a
hydraulic or a pneumatic press that just
goes right into their skull and they
just drop dead to whatever is more
humane but yeah so so point being is
that all these if you can look at a
slaughterhouse or one of the garbage
dumps or if you can look at a coal power
plant if you can look at these as
villains and and see it as old code in
inertia and see yourself having
conversations with your friends and
creating new code
as exactly what we need to do to
obsolete the old ones this is a really
powerful story and I like how you
synthesize it into the inertia villain
okay that's what I do I mean I take I
take the stuff we know and I give it
right back to you a little bit different
yeah and sort of help us grasp it a
little better
yeah just such a unique skill we need
more synthesizers and that requires more
people to be polymaths which also the
massive this gated institutional
narrative also the sociopathic and
pathological institutions around us they
don't like polymaths they don't like
people that have deep breath that can
make unique novel connections that can
synthesize a story tell in ways that
inspire and engage people and we need
more of those and I think that's the
role of what your worldview is in this
sense what about um logic leaps let's
hit those two do we can we get well I
was okay so kind of talking about go
ahead you know what effect we should
probably talk a little if you want to
ask a little more about like what I'm
doing any bio whatever but it doesn't
talk about the future we I mentioned
effect indeterminacy this sort of like
what we sort of weighted as you know
some people are negative about the
future and some people were positive and
there's too tight so I'm like no you're
the same type and the very asking Flitz
your mind and you don't know whether to
be positive or negative and confused
about it but doesn't matter that's a
really common mental pitfall or trap
that I see is what I would call this
sort of the book we call we nicknamed
attending bio the black hole effect okay
which is this tendency when you're
looking at a world problem to sort of
black holes start to suck everything
around the man and the whole universe
can get such a villain inertia is too
strong I see you look at a problem and
people
really quickly start saying the real
problem is capitalism itself
the real problem is industrial
agriculture or influenced by capitalism
the real problem is human nature you
know and where you just started with a
very particular problem like fire the
bees dying in the winter hmm and it's
the real it was just just black hole
everything into this ok and and the
tendency that if you're actually trying
to work on that problem that that kind
of thinking that sort of boiling the
ocean way of thinking is not helpful
it's definitely a privilege that no
startup gets to indulge they they don't
you don't get to fix you know end
capitalism and then solve their problem
I've got to solve a problem you know
fighting capitalism with better
capitalism they've got a you know use
venture capitalists and hedge funds to
try to solve their problem and they have
to work in a market economy and that
this it's really be careful about this
oh we're doing it it's understanding
when you begin to sort of thinking about
the problem often that becomes a
distraction from seeing like a potential
solution or a real solution
I mentioned bees and so I just think
like we have a company that went to in
Dubai a year ago B flow yeah and in
these phenomena s-- data after a year um
and you know they're at least so far all
the trials there's not just saving the
bees I mean that bees are crazy healthy
and they're saving the plants and and
you know that they're doing it and
tackle it they're doing it with a hedge
fund and with the world's largest berry
farm or industrial agriculture they're
saving the bees and and they're in ski
incite was fundamentally that right
pesticides are stupid pesticides are
designed to kill insects and the bees
and insects so I would use a pesticide
like it's crazy but that right there on
the flower
plants and insects bees in this case
share compounds so there's very same
compounds that make heal a plant can
heal the bees and if you exchange those
those plant compounds with the bees the
other thing is the bees bees love to do
their work and the more they visit any
flower the better the berries will be
off that flower and the healthy of the
bees will be and so using their science
and their AI and their study of B flight
made them into this sort of service
where it's like they're kicking ass and
but and sure you could say everybody I
asked my 15 year old daughter you know
what's the problem with the bees all the
real problem is capital so you have to
use some of the old code these old ruts
some of the inertia systems as you're
designing some of the new codes to maybe
fund or to market to some of those
companies to to kind of propagate out
the new codes sometimes you have to use
the old ones well I wonder if this is
its own code I mean I don't know like I
think we have to be more precise like it
depends on where you're getting the
money from just like where it depends on
but that's very important I'd managed to
work on Wall Street so I would let me
split the difference here I would say
that largely equity investors for the
most part Bo find plenty of exceptions
for the most part are putting in large
chunks of money into a corporation
because they believe in its plan to
change or the change is trying to make
happen and I would be but say largely
loans debt long-term debt jumped at
high-yield debt its arbitrage is that
the world won't change so if you go back
to coal
you know largest bankruptcy in history
Warren Buffett lost tons of money
earlier in the decade TRX a big LBO
big coal energy plants in Texas Oklahoma
wherever was thirty seven billion
dollars and they were counting on the
world not changing then the world
changed and they lost all this money
that borrowing money like
you see a corporation being a resistant
to change you can pretty much guess that
they've borrowed money and that
borrowing means the world can't change
on us otherwise we won't we all pay off
this debt so I would you know I really
say like have some rigor when we look at
say the old code of capitalism fight
capital is a better capitalism like pick
out the parts that are working and
change and edit the parts that aren't
working yeah okay so and I have a good
code from inertia and then change and
edit or obsolete the old ones mm-hmm
yeah I mean if you just look at that a
particular example where I'm a call the
reason is coal plants are being run I
mean they're unprofitable like I
described
okay well other political power and this
and that but ultimately they're running
the plants at a loss because they still
keep some from having to write down the
whole plant and to pay off the bonds
that they and the debt that they
borrowed to build the power plant
billion-dollar proper in the first place
years ago obligation I want you to teach
us about warp-speed effect - yeah so
warp-speed effect is this tendency when
we hear about a new technology too
quickly like a warp-speed way ahead
CRISPR oh delight our babies it's not
always negative I mean sometimes it's
positive you know like oh we got this
thing immunotherapy cancers over you
know like there's so much work that goes
into these things and I would say not
only are you missing all of those steps
to understand what's really going to
happen but that
we that if we engage the ideas only on
the broadest sense then we're only sort
of consuming the idea and then we're
constantly looking for the next idea in
the next study the next cool technology
the next cool technology rock oh I've
heard of all those concrete
dematerialization technologies are right
about that five years ago give me the
new one right and we all and I'm like we
didn't even get that last one in yet to
implement it that was had a start up on
that one yeah or you know like where
that ones that was still haven't seen
stage like you're racing ahead to the
new one and we we put ourselves in a
very sort of precarious and ungrounded
spot when we sort of race ahead to these
things it's one of the things that we
have to be sort of even and just sort of
discussing the future around a bio it's
like we really try to stay within like
don't don't talk about stuff that's
beyond like at night if you want to but
around here
let's talk about stuff that's in the 20s
25 years you know period of time we're
all gonna be working in a lot like the
period of time when of the UN
sustainable goals that's mostly talked
about stuff in the next 12 years and not
get fanciful and way out there cuz just
too much has gotta be done here yeah I
believe that we do go there sort of an
evolution cuz we're just kind of hit the
accelerate button and we try to imagine
what the future is going to be we go
there often to displace our fear of the
near the near future is very scary so
we'd go to the far future to avoid the
fear and the problems of the near future
so it's like an escapism we want to see
what's in that space and that
possibility space too so these like
abstract synthesizers can then create
what is in the potential possibility
space in the creative endeavoring of
running these permutations of startups
and seeing what they can do and then
they explain it to others and then then
we kind of get to say well maybe these
couple aren't as it won't be as optimal
as these other ones so let's run
these first but the new technologies can
come out that can maybe even leapfrog so
what the old ones are doing there's a
lot of nuance to that point but I face
gets into this a lot like Arvin
challenged me to go look for life on
other planets and has a tough is yeah
how am I gonna do that right what's that
gotta go didn't sell it I see Robo Titan
no no but I mean I'm not going to Europe
hood Titan like I'm I got to go look for
it like now I'm gonna I did like a few
weeks ago gonna go to like Antarctica or
something no so I did it I I figured out
how to do it which was I went to I found
this professor of astronomy at Caltech
Greg Hallinan who discovered a rogue
planet figured out how he had done it
learned what he was doing down the Owens
Valley and Californians at photometry
through the Kepler telescope no so
Kepler and tests are doing observations
of planets without knowing whether
they're habitable and you can sort of
say well other than have a little zone
or in the Goldilocks era but in the end
the planets got to have a magnetic field
to assist it to hold on to its
atmosphere in the presence of coronal
mass ejections which are rule you know
Mars used to have an atmosphere and had
life on it and when it lost its magnetic
core our Sun just destroyed and ravaged
this atmosphere really fast so what
you're looking for with the radio
telescopes is the interference from
essentially Aurora's on the the optical
telescopes have discovered these
possible planets in order to be able to
see with the radio the presence of a
magnetic field and a potential
atmosphere as you're looking for the
what is your aura you're looking for the
coronal mass ejection hitting an
atmosphere you know doing this down at
Caltech because then you can break up
the light that's shining from the host
star through the atmosphere and see if
there's oxygen or carbon that's that
would be a different telescope yeah but
yes what's wrong
once you have
you know to do that because you have to
to do that if you take a lot of
resources and you know stare it at that
planet so this is more of a way to look
at all planets all the time the entire
sky so using test database the Kepler
data yeah and then and then till the all
other telescopes are actually like like
this like they're about four feet high
and it's shaped like an antenna but a
little teepee frame pointed at the
ground and you know pointed actually
like more like a pyramid shaped and they
take in the entire and they have them
all spread out over the desert valley
where where are they Owens Valley Owens
oh yeah Goins Valley was like where Los
Angeles's water supply is well you know
forget about Jake it's Chinatown that
that place yeah and it's between Mammoth
Mountain yeah and the in your mountains
on the Eastern Sierras and middle desert
and they've got all these you know
little antennas it says since as your
camera is just there cost 200 bucks
apiece just spread out everywhere
listening at all time to all these plant
and why were you giving this challenge
for the book for the book yeah that'd be
fun yeah figure out a goal look alive
another planet yeah that's good chapter
yeah it is and sending Arvind to Poland
for seeing the inertia of villain
inertia is also is also a really good
way of piecing together what needs to be
done to to tackle the inertia of the
villains Poe a couple other thoughts on
the way for those that are like around
the world that are that are tuning in
that don't have like a local accelerator
maybe around them or that or don't
necessarily have mentors or
entrepreneurs around them what are the
things that you can recommend people to
do to to get inspired or engaged around
tackling some of the inertia around
villains and deploying new codes that's
that's a great question I think about
this all the time
because I was attracted to de barro
because it's not a think tank it's a do
tank right it's not an ivory tower it's
an IRA basement all right like they're
doing stuff there and I wanted to get
out of the mode of just thinking and so
you're asking fundamentally to to a
woken world that wants to get involved
doesn't quite know how to do it how to
apply they may be you know they're they
don't have a PhD in some field of Life
Sciences right what what is the big
collective embrace the hug that the
invite to to people who don't run the
corporations and they don't sit on
government bodies and the obvious one is
always to vote like that's the most
obvious power we have and to like use
our power for - that way way more than
we have been just way way more and I
would say like
let me try to connect it this way before
I came into bio right I I was staring at
our future as you were we all were right
and I was desperate for a plan
desperate for a plan for how the world
how is the world actually gonna unfold
yeah not just a plan to escape but even
just like our ultimate death in 12 years
sick how is it gonna happen you know
whatever way like how is this gonna get
resolved
I was desperate for this road map and I
was doing a lot of lucid dreaming in the
morning and I would play this game of 5
sided chess where one player was climate
change and one player was inequality and
one was the genomics revolution and one
was the rise of China and and I would
imagine in the years 2030 to 2040 which
one's gonna dominate which one's gonna
change a little more how's the other one
going to react morons relations running
simulations in my mind every more did it
four years is desperate for a planet and
what I have sort of come to in my time
at a new bio which doesn't have any such
plan just relentlessly experimenting was
it there is no plan there's just a way
it's just a way and that way is to
relentless the experiment and and like
the benefit and power of that the fact
that you can't just linearly or
exponentially extrapolate how the future
is going to happen that future
technology today lives in a world where
people fight back actively against it
which is never backing out of at offers
day they didn't have he didn't have to
deal with that he didn't go to heating
her and say well what happens if half a
society he was like people will be like
there'll be some people aren't happy
there'll be some a lot i'ts but
basically people so afraid of falling
behind that they will get on board and
that these technologies will happen and
the error he predicted pretty much the
1990
did happen and he was really right about
it but we're in a new era now or people
just they've got governments they've got
financial institutions
they've got TV shows they're fighting
back against their inertia is fighting
against the technological adoption that
we were creating mm-hmm and and so I
would advocate to people and listeners
that to understand the importance of a
world that the world doesn't just mutate
their world experiments and then
mutations right yeah and and i would say
experiment experiment experiment yeah
and I would say there is no plan I can
give you an answer we have to the future
we get will be the future we fought for
and exactly what to fight for and how to
fight for it is something we all have to
experiment we have to invent the way
that we all participate mm-hmm right
that's up to all of us to do that was
the first one you said was to get
engaged in the political process also to
get educated with all the content that
exists out there that can awaken us and
then educate us towards the point of
being able to politically engage more
effectively and then what are the tools
that enable that and then also
experientially how do we run all these
different permutations of possibilities
as like startups and as endeavors that
tackle things like the SDGs that tackle
the the inertia of the villains that
propagating new codes I will say
ultimately that labor strikes will be
useless and it kind of sumption strikes
are the only way to go so to stop
consuming the only way to stop inertia
be like just pick a month February yeah
and also every February we all stop
buying from ex-offender you know all of
it only way to get people's attention
punish it what at the heart yeah just
economic activity GDP yeah GDP I was I
was actually really harsh GDP get
people's a day of just no economic
activity it would be great could we do
one for
day of no economic activity as a planet
where everyone just chills the [ __ ] out
and just does not go and consume
anything all day long and we just chill
as a whole planet to turn the economy
off for a day press that pause button
for mental health but I'm talking about
it as a form of sprite as yes right
correct against someone that that isn't
an inertia the villain with deep inertia
that's and I would say that that's that
everyone's gonna stop is not gonna
happen the point is that enough people
would stop that you and you're not
symbolically hurting the economy you're
actually hurting it saying what you love
your GDP so much that's what we're going
after
mm-hmm and you know a big chunk of
civilized society just says we're gonna
we're sending your GDP in the other
direction like the till you pay
attention or trying to get that next
illicit dividend payment and I say the
labor strike doesn't work because it's
not enough people have jobs so and and
or you get the strikers at the bunch
people don't have jobs or it's like like
I guess technically Harvin's my boss
right like it like took one strike it in
Dubai oh I would be like changing my
butt like plenty of people's bosses like
they're not the bad guy like it's it's
really where it hurts like in those
actual wallet yeah the whole thing you
know where you you you you vote with
your money every single day so right and
we vote for the money every single day
we can choose to buy the plant over the
meat and we can choose to buy a
sustainable or non sustained oh and
what's quietly happening among what I
call the thrift class of people who you
know just their jobs are sort of the
underemployed kind of class is that they
are they are doing a sustainability
through simplicity they're buying tons
less and finding other ways to to be
entertained I mean it helps that video
games and podcasts and YouTube and great
intellectual shows the whole gamut of it
are largely free yep so that's super
entertaining this is one of my friends
who said it's never been more
entertaining to be poor like it's like
it's great you know and so it makes it a
lot easier and
and but they're their way of breeding
managing this and owning it is through
the spirit of and philosophy of
simplicity it's much more sustainable
lower consumption you know and you know
that that's happening and it but it's
not just like choose this over that it's
actually choose neither stop it only
then will we have people's attention
yeah damn yes strike that's our you know
with your money that's a big one to be
able to galvanize people on a whole
month of striking against something that
we don't believe in anymore that we want
to obsolete that code and also just be
very careful if there's if the man or
woman does not have their North Star
identified and they're not waking up
everyday pursuing it it's really easy to
fall into distractions and deceptions
and manipulations and things that take
people away from pursuing what brings
the most meaning and then then they
become more susceptible to interference
from those inertia villains i whatsoever
be clear i'm not advocating that i'm
advocating a lot more easy solutions of
that i sort of think that's what people
will realize is going to need to happen
yeah I actually I'm predicting that well
like that's what will happen not what I
want to happen but the tons of them
don't like tap and destroy it or not
stuff is not that yeah yeah the
short-term stuff was all the other
things that we talked about him yeah so
yeah alright this has been very solid we
have a lot more to unpack on another
conversation together this is really
cool that you've been you know
synthesizing what you've been doing an
indie bio with storytelling with also
just the way that you're like elegantly
compressing things to make it easier for
people to understand and get engaged
like go and visit a slaughterhouse go
and visit one of the coal plants go and
visit a garbage company like just go and
visit the old code mechanisms go and see
how sugary soft drinks get bottled and
all that type of stuff either you made
just do these little tiny things where
you can go and face old code and face
the villains and then
it can inspire you to get engaged
through your own education to your own
voting through your own experience or
learning and setting up entrepreneurship
yeah did these have been this has been a
solid episode poet thank you thank you
for coming on this is awesome round two
cool yeah good job
thanks man good job good job thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
have more conversations of your friends
your families co-workers people online
on social media about these perverse
incentives how we're fixing them as a
society how we're tackling these dard
the villains and the inertia they have
with entrepreneurship and creativity and
actualizing more people around our world
also check out the links in the by below
to Poe Brunson constantly calm indie bio
co SF Grado org
and also post Twitter profile and his
book list check those out everyone Thank
You ory shapiro for producing we greatly
appreciated ory and also go and support
the artists entrepreneurs the spiritual
leaders organizations around the world
that you believe in sports simulation
our links are below as well our patreon
crypto-currency paypal links are all
down there so support us and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world we love you very
much thank you for tuning in and we will
see you soon